I'm always ready standby
[Applause]
what what do you mean when I was going
to talk to that did you did you really
think I was gonna mess that up just just
that a just general curiosity you think
I was gonna fumble that just no but I
mean just your got intuition on me did
you think I was fumbling that one okay
[Music]
it's scary be
[Music]
that's it sit sit I love you back what
up Sydney good afternoon good evening
thank you so much for coming out a lot
to cover in our time here together a
couple things I want to talk about first
thing I want to talk about is the
concept of guilting people by giving so
much without expectation that it creates
the outcome that you're looking for
thanks mom
and I think it's an interesting thing
because when I come to talks I'm always
trying to provide the most value that I
possibly can and I'm trying to find
platforms that connect all of us
everybody in here is in a different
place in their journey whether it's
entrepreneurship or working in
environment startup there's just so much
different [ __ ] happening in the room
that it's hard when you speak because
you don't want to talk so narrow that
half the audience is checked out because
there's zero relevance and that's why I
love talking about attention and I'll
get to that in a minute because the one
thing I'm sure of is that every single
person here needs to understand that
they have to grab attention and then
story tell and create the action that
they want at the same token it is that
action that fascinates me nobody's
sitting here without some sort of
ambition to create something to happen
and I think there's a real huge mistake
and misunderstanding of what to be very
frank what I think has gotten me here
versus other people and other statures
and different opportunities and there's
just a very big difference between
branding and selling and I think for a
lot of you in this room there's a real
interesting conversation because you
want something to happen and either a
you can sell and I think you guys know
what selling looks like or
or you can brand and I'm intrigued by
branding because branding is funny right
like branding so many of you right now
are wearing clothes that you're wearing
not because vans tagged you right and
cookie you or gave you a special deal
for one day it's because they built a
brand and you wanted to buy it and I
would implore all of you and this is you
know for so many of you you have 10 20
30 40 50 years of your career and you
need to use that as leverage because
when you have time on your hands you can
run a marathon instead of the 99 percent
of what I see every day which is
everybody's putting on their sprinting
shoes and trying to sell and close on
the first transaction which is just not
an effective long-term strategy it has
value it works
I get it I love selling stuff I love
selling my new case with sneakers I love
selling wine I love selling books I like
it but there's such a better way if
you're playing the long game and I think
it's about bringing value the thing that
I obsess about I mean I literally have
been reading and I know because I see
you guys see me interacting with you
I'm literally reading your two tweets in
the back room and liking it right I'm
engaging and paying attention and trying
to figure out how am I going to bring
value to this specific audience this
specific time in an environment where I
know a lot of you have already watched
plenty of my content like how the [ __ ]
do you figure that out and it's
intriguing to me that as I go down the
path of success I'm trying harder to
bring value not the other way around and
look to me that is the framework to me
the framework is legacy not currency to
me the framework is doing the right
thing is always the right thing to me
the things that are making the people
achieve going forward I'm a friends why
do you think all this stuff is happening
in Hollywood right now the truth is
going to be undefeated the internet is
now the middleman
for retail for media for our society
that is the way it is now the Internet
is the middleman which means nobody's in
control except for the end
audience at scale you may sit here and
dwell because you're a defensive minded
person and think somebody's controlling
[ __ ] Facebook's not controlling [ __ ]
Facebook's exposing you because you're
the one liking that [ __ ] so we sit
around and we dwell and we go on defense
and we think and all this and what we
need is dramatic accountability you know
many people in this audience right now
say that they are passionate about too
many things and that's why they haven't
done anything that's a [ __ ] excuse to
not do you're not too talented and too
many things
you're [ __ ] lazy and so I'm really
intrigued by a lot that's going on but
the thing that I know more than anything
is that we are living through the single
greatest era for humans ever right now I
know that word the bunny you know
deploying plenty of things that were
upset about and there's a lot of tension
in the air and I think that's
appropriate I just don't think that we
put things into context you may not be
happy about certain things in technology
or politics or business or what-have-you
but that's a hell of a lot better than
the Black Plague and so to me it is like
I know [ __ ] sucks sometimes but like
remember Hitler so so I'm extremely
optimistic
I'm extremely positive what's going on
and it's all because of the framework of
this talk this thing you have to how
many people do not have a cell phone
raise your hand cool zero by the way for
everybody in the front rows this thing
is ridiculously powerful this thing is
the remote control of our society
this thing has eliminated every excuse
out of your [ __ ] mouth because if you
have to work 9 to 6 to pay the bills
pay your dues to pay your debts that is
exactly right and appropriate everybody
comes from different starting points
I have unbelievable of empathy to that
the exciting thing though is that our
grandparents didn't have this thing they
had to work 9:00 to 6:00 9:00 to 7:00
and then there was only so much upside
that they could create for themselves
long term from 7:00 to 2:00 in the
morning
this thing has fundamentally changed
everything and I just think we take it
for granted
I really wish everybody understood the
power that's literally sitting in their
hands right now this is literally a
media creation and distribution tool
that would have cost tens of millions of
dollars if you understand distribution
the technology probably cost twenty
thousand dollars you know 25 years ago
cameras they said fine the distribution
you would have a shoot a satellite into
space you would have had to buy a
printing press you would have had to buy
trucks you would have had it done so
much the fact that every person here can
literally turn this on themselves create
content around something they're
interested in and then have platforms
like YouTube and Facebook and Instagram
and Twitter and LinkedIn distribute it
let me remind you at no cost is so
batshit crazy for all of us old [ __ ]
in here that I just wish people would
not take it for granted and so my
friends I come here tonight to really
try to pull off one move can I actually
take somebody even if they're a huge fan
or if they've never heard of me before
and tweak their perspective on what's
actually going on can I convince one of
you that nobody gives a [ __ ] about your
headaches and problems and when you
complain you're just taking minutes off
the board and energy off the board from
doing something about it literally I am
fascinated by the inability to be held
accountable I am fascinated that you
actually are coming up and spending
energy and trying to say why you're not
successful because your older brother
did some [ __ ] in 1996 and so I'm sorry I
mean it's super interesting to me I read
and read and read I don't watch outside
of watching New York Jets football and
now the Knicks are starting I maybe try
to do something so a little Knicks
basketball like I could sue nothing but
your comments and I get into rabbit
holes you know Wikipedia or YouTube
you start off watching something and
then three hours later you're watching
like penguins like [ __ ] on each
other that's what I do with comments you
guys leave comments 80% of it like you
know is like something that is either
overwhelmingly like I'm the Messiah
which you can keep doing that I feels
great or I'm a snake oil salesman in a
piece of [ __ ] I love that even more by
the way keep feeding me you [ __ ]
losers okay but the 20% super
interesting to me which is you know say
something and of that 20% 10% say
something really intriguing I'm a little
bit of an enigma I'm an interesting kind
of character in the way that I
communicate versus my actions actually
watch this how many people you honest
remember lying is the devil how many
people here honestly the first time or
two that they came across me thought I
was a [ __ ] and didn't like me raise
your hands raise them high oh that's a
little too many and so knowing that
truth I am always fascinated because I'm
able to judge people on how they react
to me a lot of the people that raised
their hands were in a mindset at the
time of not being comfortable being
suffocated from the excuse that they
were comfortable if you ask me when I
look at my content and take myself out
of it the thing that I'm doing is I'm
putting pressure I'm putting pressure
and I'm using the truth as my pressure
point which is making me successful and
why so many people benefit from me
because once you can flip over and once
you can start actually taking full
accountability like it's crazy
my parent you know it's funny when I
talk about myself it's all about Sasha
and tomorrow Vaynerchuk like all the
good [ __ ] that's happening with me I'm
like I had nothing you know when you
guys you're the best I'm like cool my
parents you know being an immigrant like
America capitalism like I if Misha and
Xander crush it if vaynermedia crushes
it you know like data can be like that
to me but like when I think about what
my parents did and what my circumstance
and
did I'm just incapable of a doing
anything for anybody and expecting
anything in return you want to live a
very happy life create the framework
that I did naturally I don't know if I
created it or if it was given to me the
greatest version of life I've ever seen
is the one I'm living which is nobody
ever disappoints you because you never
expected anything from anybody I'm
telling you right now you want to talk
about why so many of you aren't exactly
where you want to be look deep inside
yourself on what your expectations of
others are and then the worst [ __ ] of
you are the ones that do [ __ ] expecting
something more in return that's my
favorite that's like the ten emails I
got today Gary Vee I'll buy you lunch
when you're in Sydney
yeah that sounds [ __ ] rad Rick I
can't wait to get that $8 sandwich for a
[ __ ] hour and a half session my
friends accountability giving with no
expectation in return playing the long
game every single person's business or
ambition will grow exponentially
tomorrow if they spend the next 13 years
giving away free content forever seems
supernatural when do you monetize how do
you do this the person holds the breath
the longest wins you know it's just very
simple the problem is is there's so many
people here that are just not patient
and you're not paying you know the
youngsters aren't patient because they
have chips on their shoulder because
they want to prove to mom and dad that
they're right and they're gonna do it
their way
and they the second they start doing
their process they've got the pressure
on them what you know they haven't made
it yet this is all about shortcuts
versus the long game I spent the first
13 years of my career building my dad's
liquor business for him I was 34 years
old had no money to my name owned 0% of
Wine Library and started vaynermedia
with AJ by getting somebody to pay us
$80,000 before we did the campaign
because I had no dollars I decided to
spend the first 13 years of my life
working 15 hours a day to build my dad's
business for him because I felt so
thankful for what my parents did
for me so when people say easy for you
or this and that I'm like look at my
narrative like you know how many of you
are not 34 years old younger younger
than 34 raise your hands all of you that
just raise your hands
I never made $100,000 a year like think
about how much time you actually have I
honed my skills I've learned how to
build a business but everybody's so
impatient lack of patience and
entitlement are the frameworks to why
people aren't successful here I'm
talking very heavy [ __ ] off the gate
because before I get to the examples of
what you should do on Facebook and
Instagram and how influencer marketing
is working and we're the white space in
our industry and voice and Alexis skills
and all the [ __ ] you know I'm gonna go
into in a minute before I get there if
your [ __ ] mind isn't right it doesn't
matter how you execute and for the
people that are over 45 and above over
45 and above if you're still trying to
get yours you need to understand that
the [ __ ] if you're not satisfied if
you're not where you want to be you need
to understand that you've had time now
to play and the way you've been playing
it isn't working just important to
understand that now if you're pumped and
you're awesome then [ __ ] you won and
by the way this isn't a money game if
you make fifty seven thousand dollars a
year and have the work/life balance that
you want your happiest [ __ ] you [ __ ]
won I know people making eight million
dollars a year they're [ __ ] miserable
hate the [ __ ] lights and I've friends
who make sixty seven thousand dollars
eaters loving life for softball teams
and [ __ ] love it it's not a dollars
and cents [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] how
much money you make do you feel pumped
as [ __ ] when you wake up like I do like
I barely [ __ ] sleep you know on these
kind of trips and I can't wait to get
over here and talk to you about it
because I [ __ ] love it I love
grinding I loved all the fires I had to
put out in the green room I loved that
we lost any million dollar pitch today I
loved it I loved it
I mean it
because I don't want the stuff I don't
want the stuff everybody wants to
[ __ ] stuff you want the stuff cuz
it's closing a gap of insecurity or not
happiness that's what you want you want
a nice [ __ ] so other people think you're
good because you're not confident within
your own self like when you start
actually figuring out how not to give a
[ __ ] about anybody else's opinion for
real and I'm talking about your spouse
and your children and your parents that
deep let alone your [ __ ] neighbor or
your homey from around the way [ __ ] gets
really [ __ ] quiet in here [ __ ] gets
real good in here and I am desperate to
figure out why you feel like you aren't
in that place what is it
parenting I get it I know why I'm just
trying to get you to realize what are
you waiting for to change the reason I
talk randomly about going and visiting
retirement homes is cuz I want you to
see what regret and resentment looks
like at 90 years old the reason I think
the number one thing that every person
in this room should do is go and
volunteer in a retirement home next week
for a day is because a it's a nice deed
and they'll love it
but you are gonna get disproportionately
more value out of it because you're
gonna look at a stranger who's not your
grandparent and you're gonna Jam you'll
talk and you'll interact and I promise
you when you see 90 year old regret or
resentment from not doing or living
their lives by somebody else's point of
view
aka their parents you will get so
[ __ ] scared it will completely change
the course of how you do [ __ ] if it
stuns me that people's self-esteem in
this room ours wrapped up and how many
Instagram followers they have it stuns
me in the [ __ ] that we do because of
other people's opinions the reason I've
been able to deploy patience is because
when I was 29 years old and worked for
my daddy's liquor store and my other
friends were at Wall Street and making
200 thousand a year
I didn't give a [ __ ] I didn't give a
[ __ ] because I knew how it was gonna all
end up I knew exactly who I was I
laughed
that you guys think I'm doing something
right now I haven't even [ __ ] started
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious with you
and so and so I have spent the last two
or three years spending more time trying
to figure out what the [ __ ] how did they
build me like this what was the
circumstance that got me here and how
the hell do I pass on anything to you I
realize the reason I give away all my
best stuff for free is because if you
get some it's not gonna come out of my
expense I love how many of you think
you've got some big idea that you can't
share with anybody and you want people
to sign NDA's the [ __ ] are matter with
you
ideas are completely a commodity I'll
give you every idea of every business
that's gonna work I'll give you a
thousand of them in eSports and AI and
machine learning and blockchain and
crypto and I'll go on and I'll give you
everything
I'll give them every single thing the
problem is ideas are like knowing you
should do push-ups knowing you should do
push-ups versus doing push-ups is a very
big difference
I am always talking about hustle and
hard work and people like to razz me too
much too much the only reason I talk
about that is it's not interesting for
me to sit here and tell you to become
smarter imagine if this talk was like
hey guys be smarter there's zero
practicality in that the one guaranteed
controllable thing for this entire
audience row by row is if your work more
more could happen if you work I love
when people like hey Gary but they you
know raise the hand and Oh cute hey Gary
listen you talk about working hard but
I'm working smart and that's working and
I'm like cool bro but I'm working hard
and smart so [ __ ] you
guys we are living through a
ridiculously phenomenal era and let me
explain what it is it's called the
Facebook era first point of advice if
you do not spend an ungodly amount of
your time and energy on Facebook and
Instagram regardless of what you do
regardless of what you do I'm talking
you're targeting 50 to 80 year olds in a
b2b environment so I'm going to say this
nice and slow I'm a businessman not a
social media guru listen very carefully
if you are not spending a
disproportionate about your money and
time and energy in 2018 on Facebook and
Instagram
you are leaving significant upside for
what you're trying to achieve on the
table this ship has sailed this is not a
debatable issue anymore and when I look
at the prices for the Australian market
of attention it's even better than the
US market when I look at the Australian
influencers what they're asking for for
shoutouts and compared to the US market
even though they're getting more organic
reach not less it's not even funny how
many people here sell a physical product
raise your hands
all of you that are be deeply become
practitioners and what Instagram
influencers marketplace looks like how
much does it cost to have somebody on
Instagram with a following shout out
your product whether she or he has 3000
fans or 1.9 million there is an
arbitrage and because people don't know
how to price themselves some are asking
for too much some are asking for too
little but it's an inefficient
marketplace that you could take
advantage of because I don't know if you
guys heard but people are [ __ ] living
on this device literally literally I
almost had a heart attack in the green
room because I was in the green room I
went to go take a piss I put my phone
down and it started sliding my life
flashed before my eyes the thought that
this would go into the toilet and I
would not be able to have a phone for a
day and a half blew my [ __ ] face off
my body
this is the single most important
literally I have a wallet on me [ __ ] I
would literally rather somebody come up
here shoot me with a gun and steal my
passport than lose my phone why is that
it's because the world runs through this
now
you may think that's sad because you
grew a pre cell phone you might think
that's sad because you reminisce of the
days you had a pager and that was super
cool you may think that's sad because
you don't like the kids being on it too
much or when you go out to dinner it's
not nice that the couple sitting there
and both on the phone and that's not the
way it should be according to you Sally
but technology in society doesn't give a
[ __ ] about how you think it should be it
just does what it does and it is your
job to adjust to the reality of the
situation and the reality the situation
is if you do not know how to make
written words pictures or video or audio
sound for the phone that we all hold in
our hand across the 10 platforms called
Facebook Instagram snapchat YouTube
LinkedIn blah blah blah you are
irrelevant let me make this perfectly
clear if you think Google AdWords and
email and direct mail and events and
everything else are gonna get you to the
next chapter you will lose all those
things I mentioned work they're just
either priced appropriately or grossly
overpriced while the things I just
talked about prior to that are grossly
underpriced if you pay the appropriate
price for Google and Direct Mail and
your competitor under buys attention on
Facebook and Instagram you will lose
that is how it's always happened if
you're baffled how the biggest companies
in the world continue to go out of
business it's because of the thing that
I just talked about now let me tell you
what's gonna happen
over the next five years because of
vaynermedia and this is why I
strategically did it for many other
reasons we work with Budweiser and Pepsi
and GE and the biggest companies in the
world none of these companies are
remotely close spending enough money on
Facebook not even close
when they wake up like they did on
Google in 2009 and 10 even though I was
buying attention two thousand one two
three four five when they wake up which
they're about two years away from waking
up and they start pouring the right
amount of money into those platforms you
will no longer be paying $6 CPMs in
front of any citizen in Australia that
you want targeted to Asian or African
American or a footy fan or somebody who
drinks beer who likes Hunter Valley
Semyon or all the other things that you
can do on Facebook yet you don't know
this because you guys aren't
practitioners you have opinions on
Facebook advertising you just have never
run any facebook [ __ ] ads when that
happens in 24 months and they start
spending the right money you're not
gonna have enough money to reach the
people nobody here is running to the TV
station to run tons of television
commercials because they're too
expensive for you and that's what's
going to happen on Facebook and
Instagram and you're gonna think back to
this talk and be really [ __ ] pissed
that you were super fired up when Gary
became but a week later you went back to
the same [ __ ] habits that got you
there in the first place
and I am putting pressure on this
conversation with the deep hope the
passion that you have the humility to
start actually doing the work required
to achieve the [ __ ] that's coming out of
your mouth I am fascinated by how many
people here are gonna build a
million-dollar business and aren't
putting in enough work or enough
research and smarts to get even close to
that place while we have the greatest
era ever let me explain if this was a
business talk in 1974 and I was telling
you stuff you'd have to go to the
library to read [ __ ] books
to get more detailed information when I
was done the fact that everybody here
who has no [ __ ] idea how to make a
snapchat filter or run a YouTube
pre-roll on a video based on the queries
and searches that person made on Google
or how to do targeted Facebook RSVP
event advertising that is grossly
underpriced or how to price or even
begin to price an Instagram influencer
that's asking for amount of money the
fact that you guys have and you might
want to write this down this incredible
resource for free G Oh Oh G
Oh com the fact that you have that
watching people write this down is
making me laugh the fact that you have
Google and you can type in how do i
price Instagram influencers enter and
thirty three minutes later be somewhat
decently educated on what to do and yet
everybody's throwing up their hands and
saying Gary I don't get all this [ __ ]
you didn't get driving you have figured
it out we are in a place where we are
not putting in the work we are in a
place where we are not accepting the
gravitas of the situation which is I'm
gonna say it again the single greatest
era to be an entrepreneur because the
internet is now at scale guys when I
started selling wine on the Internet in
1997 most people didn't have a computer
let alone be on the internet I would
literally go to things and be like you
want to buy some wine on the internet or
actually I didn't call it the Internet
you want to buy some wine on the
information superhighway people didn't
even know I would ask for people's email
addresses and didn't even know like you
it would be like if I'm talking to you
right now about VR infrastructure or the
way that a lot of you don't understand
the blockchain or a theory and you try
to talk about Bitcoin like you know
something you have no idea what you're
talking about right like that that's how
the internet was in 97 the fact that all
of us are now in a place where this
entire room has a cellphone device
internet access
and has one two three of these apps
downloaded and that you can produce on
that platform and it costs you let me
say it again
nothing and you could speak about
Facebook at school but you could still
go organic you could it's why you should
really focus on Instagram because thirty
forty percent organic for now is a hell
of a lot interesting in my opinion
especially when you get to become a
practitioner and you start putting
fifteen hashtags around your industry
and your product and you have people
discover you for let's say one more time
free yet we do not have the humility to
put in the work it baffles my mind that
you have not spent 100 hours in research
on snapchat LinkedIn Facebook and
Instagram marketing you think you're
gonna outsource it to your 13 year old
niece you think it's not gonna matter
you think a new apps gonna come along
that's fine but I'm gonna tell you right
now the regret in this room to not going
all in on those platforms during this
era is going to be quite high in four or
five years when everybody realizes what
we just lived through I have enormous
regret my only business regret in my
career is that I did not spend enough
money on Google during 2002 to 2005 when
I was building my dad's liquor store
because I had words for five cents a
clip and I didn't understand how good of
a deal it was words that I spent 10
cents a click for are now eight dollars
six dollars four dollars it changed it
came and went I built a big business for
my dad on the back of it but it could
have been much bigger ya might be doing
a little Facebook and a little bit of
Instagram but you're not doing enough it
is underpriced and by the way this whole
ten minute rant just so everybody knows
I don't give a [ __ ] if you do anything I
just said I'm putting this on film to
just be historically correct you're not
my sister I don't care
and so I implore you I've got nothing to
[ __ ] sell you girls and boys I'm
trying to sell legacy here and be right
so please figure out why you're not
doing what I just said and usually comes
from hard core human flaws
Audacity ego just don't want to do the
work you know even working hard on other
things you don't wanna do the work
you'll have time my friends way bigger
companies than yours are about to go out
of business over the next five years
because they're under estimating this I
just want everybody here way bigger
companies than yours are about to go out
of business and are going out of
business in America Toys R Us has gone
out of business there's news companies
in this country but there's real [ __ ]
going on you haven't seen anything yet I
want to remind you that 13 years ago
everything we just talked about doesn't
exist
not the [ __ ] iPhone not Facebook not
YouTube nothing this has happened in 12
years you know and for us that are 40 42
and older that's like yesterday I
understand if you're 19 that seems like
a long time it won't seem and in 10
years everything that we're talking
about now is [ __ ] this iPhone X
that's so post-fight so [ __ ] rad this
is literally a piece of Dookie in ten
years what do you think we're going what
I think is gonna happen with machine
learning and AI and crypto where do you
think this is all going so if you
haven't fully immersed yourself into a
hardcore digital world that's like you
not running on the treadmill leading up
to the longest marathon of your life
what do you think it's gonna go
backwards shut down the Internet
we're gonna alright letters it's gonna
be really [ __ ] sweet what do you
think the world's going and so please I
beg you to take this talk this moment
this night to have the cold shower that
I'm trying to deliver to recognize
you're not doing enough you're not
pushing it hard enough you're not
educated enough you're not doing the
hard work
you're just not I know it I know it and
again listen I'm sure there's plenty of
you doing all the right things cool I'm
talking about the fact that I looked at
everybody who used this hashtag today
and then spent time on my flight from
Brisbane here and in the back room
looking at what you're doing you're
mailing it in you've got the accounts to
make yourself feel good that you're
doing it what's the ROI of a piano for
me dick for Elton John a billion dollars
how many people here this time to tell
the truth cuz it's okay because it
should a lot of hands should go up how
many people here to run Facebook ads
that didn't work for them raise your
hands raise them high and I want it
stand up stand up if you ran facebook
ads and it didn't work for you what
everybody look around in my passionate
plea for the last 15 minutes and then in
the people that stood up here you guys
can sit down thank you so much is the
rub is the thing that I'm most
passionate out how many people here have
run Facebook ads that have work for them
stand up this is it this is the thing
that matters to me thank you
gets it down
so many things can work but you have to
be good at it
so many things can work but you have to
try more so many people ran Facebook ads
in that first group spend a couple
thousand bucks maybe even tens of
thousands of dollars it didn't work and
they decided that that was enough
information to deem the whole thing not
working we are making short-term
mistakes we are not investing in the
reality of understanding the only thing
that matters which is the end consumers
attention where your attention is is
where I am why did I start getting
serious about my podcast in December of
last year here's why how many people
here consume my content raise your hand
thank you of those people how many in
the last year have started listening to
my podcast or listened to my podcast
raise your hand
thank you how many in the last year have
started listening more to the podcast
and consuming less of the video raise
your hand stand up and I really
appreciate going up and down I
appreciate it thank you I want people to
say look around these are people who in
2017 started listening to radio more
than watching television these are
people who've been listening more to my
podcast than watching video sit down
thank you so much because these are
people who value their time so much that
they subconsciously figured out that
they could get the information but they
could be doing something else in
parallel while they're listening to the
information so that they could do two
things instead of one because we
continue to grossly underestimate our
capability my friends texting and
driving super dangerous right plenty of
more people die from that than we report
right but you know how many people
should die from texting and driving
everyone it is super hardcore that
you're not looking at the road and
you're looking at a phone the reality is
is that humans can do multiple things at
once we grossly underestimate us we're
about to live in the growing era of
voice get ready for the next five to
seven years all of the action all of
this unbeliev
underpriced attention is coming to a
voice next to you it's going to be in
podcast form right now over next half
decade between Amazon Alexa and Google
home and Apple home pod and I Facebook
better [ __ ] figure it out
and whoever else is playing they are
gonna produce things and every single
person here is gonna be brushing their
teeth seven years now out of toothpaste
they're gonna spit it and they're gonna
say something like Alexa reorder my
toothpaste and it will Alexa don't
forget to bring Mary an anniversary
present tomorrow do you want me to buy
the anniversary present sure cool lack
of friction every person here gives away
everything for speed you overpay you
give money for speed you give up your
privacy for speed
you guys put your social security
numbers credit cards addresses
everything just so that your phone won't
ask you for the password again we are
living through the biggest shift in
human culture since the printing press
became a media source that dictated our
thoughts this is a big deal this isn't a
what's a marketing campaign I can come
up with or what's an app that's gonna be
next Gary so I can be on it this is a
it's happening right in your [ __ ]
face and you're not doing anything about
it so look you could get fired up you
could take courses you can read books
you can do anything you want
I implore you to do none of that and
start actually doing nothing would make
me happier than if every person in this
room stopped watching my content and
spent their time testing and learning
the theories that I've shoved down your
[ __ ] throat for the last two years
because the only way shits gonna happen
is if you do and you can sit around and
ponder and debate and tell me why no or
why it's bad
where this and that all you're doing is
layering excuse on top of excuse to not
doing the thing you don't want to do
which is go learn something for 48 hours
or 97 hours or 400 hours and then go
work 15 hours a day to achieve the [ __ ]
that's coming out of your mouth period
end of story and what makes me sad is
unlike 1984 and 1992 and 1967 if you
actually did what I'm telling you to do
you would get disproportionate dollars
disproportionate impact and
disproportionate growth in a shorter
period of time than any generation prior
to us from this day back
greatest theory ever most entitlement
ever greatest theory ever most excuses
ever and that's what living through
there's a couple people who are doing
something about it and a lot of good
things are happening for them so look I
think it's hardcore for me like you know
I'm sitting here I'm like [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] do I just get them to do this like
how do I get them to understand how
ridiculous it is watch what I do not
what I say there's a reason I didn't put
out a lot of content in 2012 13 14 it's
cuz there was nothing remotely this
interesting Facebook was still growing
in its product and its scale right
Twitter was an effective selling
mechanism it was a great Community
Builder and for branding incredible I
want to remind you that's how I got here
right and we weren't there yet
frictionless payment this and that we've
just weren't there yet
the reason I've gotten so loud and
traveling over the world two times over
in a [ __ ] week is because I'm
desperate to put it on film and be
historically correct I'm desperate for
one of you to email me three years from
now and say you know what it was the
Sydney talk that finally got me out of
my [ __ ] and I got educated and I won
hard on LinkedIn following your model
like that's what I'm looking for and so
please please one two three of you
because that's where I'm at been doing
this a long time everybody's sitting
there saying yeah this is it I'm gonna
do it and
next Thursday happens and you lose a
client and you go on defense so please
be that person that fulfills the
strategy that I'm deploying here a
couple other things how many people here
have employees raise your hand
great let's talk about a couple random
things as little footnotes on the way
out hiring how many people here are
struggle with hiring good it's wrapped
up in your ego it's not about hiring
it's about firing too many people how
many people struggle with hiring me to
include it one more time too many of you
don't want to admit that you've made the
wrong hire so you hold on to somebody
that it's black and white that you
should be firing but you don't want to
do it because your ego is wrapped up
because you're a good hire and you could
are gonna figure it out and fix it it's
the most interesting psychology and
business that I've seen I'm fascinated
by it and that's why I wanted to throw
it out here it's not about being great
at hiring it's about being great at
firing number two if you aren't firing
the person that's making the most money
for you but they're the biggest piece of
[ __ ] and suck for the other boys and
girls you will long term lose if you
were holding on to somebody who's
straight [ __ ] cancer but delivering
on the field you will lose look at every
sports team in the history when there
isn't continuity and good vibes no
matter how much talent that team has
they [ __ ] lose wonder why because
it's the way it's played it's how humans
work no one person matters enough have
the bravery to get rid of that person
because it is hurting your long-term
upside most of you don't want to do that
because that means you have to go back
in and do something to that person's
covering and you deserve to lose and
your company will lose so those are my
two things on hiring real quick well
I've got you this millennial talk is
such horseshit it pisses me the [ __ ] off
listen to all you old [ __ ] claim that
Millennials are entitled and lazy is so
[ __ ] boring and so sad and shows how
big of a [ __ ] loser you are it's
incredible you're gonna tell me how many
people are 40 and older raise your hands
you're gonna tell me you didn't have a
bunch of lazy [ __ ] around you back in
the day
it is ridiculous and it is a terrible
mindset and it's absolutely hurting so
many of you because you're disrespecting
technology and the reality of the game
this is the greatest generation there
are much better human beings as a whole
than we are sure some of them suck
because some of us suck in every
generation yes do a lot of them have an
entitlement issue absolutely it's not
their fault the world's been good for
too long
super easy to complain about not getting
a whole lot of likes when people aren't
going to war and getting killed so you
can't be mad at them because the world
got good for a long time we've lost
perspective I also want to remind most
of the 40 and olders we're the ones that
created these kids
everybody's protecting little Sal from
not losing made him a [ __ ] loser
eighth place trophies don't win how many
people have more than 20 employees raise
your hand little fun facts super
interesting to me something has really
helped me just try to throw some random
[ __ ] out here I hope you're in the
mindset that you work for them not the
other way around the number one thing
that has worked for me is I genuinely
believe I work for everybody that works
for me right I work for them it is the
only mindset it's what I started this
talk with my fault my this right this
$8,000,000 pitch we lost today I didn't
touch it at all my people did I hear the
news I'm like I [ __ ] up didn't make
the Dec didn't go to meeting was not
part of anything
I [ __ ] up because I hired those people
I'm the last line of defense it's me
another thing that always blew my mind
about my dad and other people that I
watch they expect their employees to
work as hard as them makes me laugh how
the [ __ ] do you expect somebody to work
as hard as you when you own the thing if
you want your employees to work as hard
as you give them equal equity to what
you have a miraculous thing will happen
they'll start working as hard as you I
have a funny feeling that's not the
trade that you want to make
so become far more realistic about your
expectations and look at what you're
compensating and then on compensation if
you're lucky and next year I have 800
employees next year I will mandate
spending 15 minutes with every one of my
employees every six months it is gonna
eat up an ungodly amount of my time my
entire mission in that time is to get to
know who they are a little bit more get
them a little more comfortable to tell
me the truth because we have an actual
relationship and build context on what
drives them because there's plenty of
people who want money there's plenty of
people who want a bigger title work/life
balance travel I actually don't care I
just need to know what they are if
you're unbelievable you can have them
all if you kind of suck you're gonna
have to pick one but the reality is is I
need to put them in a position to tell
me what it is and I'm quadrupling down
on the context with my employees way too
many of us spend way too much energy on
customers and nowhere close to enough
unemployed and I promise you if you
reverse that your organization's will
feel the financial impact in a very
significant way gentleman who introduced
me said something to me today this
morning in Brisbane I said you know
everything I'm trying to do here is
predicated on trying to figure out what
people are saying behind my back and he
said to me that you know it's a real
pleasure to have you here Gary you know
I got to tell you it's interesting I do
this a lot you do this a lot it's super
interesting how people talk about you
back here in the setup room and how many
nice things are said about you my
friends everybody's watching and now
with technology everybody's watching for
real every word every tweet every
Facebook thing you say is something that
you're gonna have to explain to your
grandchild everything you sell how you
sell it how you interact I implore you
listen it's one thing when somebody
leaves an anonymous review on our sign
says I'm a jerk because they got fired
and they sucked fine it's another thing
if somebody has never met me and I said
that their company sucks and they get
upset
they say I'm a blowhard makes sense but
the people that actually interact with
you who've spent time with you you
better make sure that you're living a
life that puts you in a position for
them to say the right thing
the only way you can do that actually in
my opinion is to have very long term
vision so many people here want it to
happen tomorrow and we're gonna live for
another 77 years so many of you are
taking shortcuts to make an extra
$15,000 tomorrow and it's gonna cost you
money for the next 44 years we are
stunningly intriguing animals with our
inability to be patient with our
desperate need to get something in the
short-term only to prove something to
everybody else because we haven't proved
it to ourselves please please please
stop playing that game because it is
binary the ones that play that game are
unhappy and lose the ones that don't are
happy and when it's crystal clear
historic this has nothing to do with
this
this shit's been around since cavemen
hit each other with a [ __ ] club
please do the right thing it always is
the right thing and that doesn't mean
just being Noble and everything I just
talked about it means putting in the
work both educating yourself on the [ __ ]
that's actually happening and then doing
the output of the work to actually
achieve the audacity that is coming out
of your mouth that you're gonna live one
of the best lives on earth I remind you
how few people everybody's an
entrepreneur now on Instagram how many
people are going to be successful
entrepreneurs is a different game and I
could change my bio on my Instagram
account right now real easy to say
rapper
I want to
but am I gonna make it I leave you with
that
do you have self-awareness do you know
who you actually are versus who you wish
you were because a lot of you are
playing based on what you wish you were
the second you figure out who the [ __ ]
you are and don't apologize for it and
surround yourself with the people that
do the things that you can't do whether
your partner or you pay them a lot of
good [ __ ] will happen and so
self-awareness and humility and empathy
and all these warm and fuzzy things that
grandma talks about happen to be the
biggest secrets in the rough-and-tumble
game of business I highly recommend you
get in touch with those emotions thank
you nice gentleman Gary Vaynerchuk
thanks guys thanks for having me let him
hear you Sidney give it up for Gary
thank you hey make a little content here
all right now really lose your [ __ ]
minds here we go go go crazy
love you guys thank you great job keep
tired one more big hand guys give it up
you're gonna punched it right there
[Applause]
give carrying on the hand guys good
stuff yes come ahead
[Applause]
[Music]